eu christian kopp
is a professor emeritus of classics at
the university of colorado boulder
where he taught for 36 years he earned
his ba at haverford college and his phd
in classics from the university of north
carolina
at chapel hill from 2004 to 2011
he served as the founding director of
the center for western civilization
a fellow of the american academy in rome
and recipient of the hero of conscience
award from the american freedom alliance
dr kopp was named maguster manus by the
consortium for classical lutheran
education
the organization's highest honor he is
the editor of a critical edition of
euripides bakkai
and author of the devil knows latin why
america needs the classical tradition
please join me in welcoming dr kopf
[Applause]
thank you for that very nice
introduction
welcome ladies and gentlemen it's
an honor to be here and i'd like to
thank hillsdale college
and the center for constructive
alternatives
for setting up this seminar on such an
important topic
and for allowing me to participate
and for giving me my topic which is
history
and the liberal arts in his dialogue day
republica
cicero has scipio explain how to begin a
speech
he says quotes i begin by observing a
rule
which all speakers i fancy must adhere
to
if confusion is to be avoided that is if
the name of the subject under discussion
is accepted whatever it is the meaning
of the name
should be explained and quotes for the
title of this talk is history in the
liberal arts so we can start off by
asking
what is history and we're going to in
fact use it in several
senses in ordinary language and in this
talk
first it may mean what happened in the
past
the battle of hastings the reign of
henry viii
the good news of jesus and how it spread
from jerusalem to rome second
history may refer to studying and
recounting the past
in many forms textbooks documentaries
works of literature like herodotus's
histories are gibbons
decline and fall third
as an academic discipline history is one
subject
among many social sciences arts
humanities and physical sciences that
comprise the undergraduate curriculum
of a liberal arts education
there were seven liberal arts that saint
augustine first catalogued
in the fourth century a.d three form the
arts of language the trivium
grammar dialectic or logic
and rhetoric four comprise the arts of
mathematics
the quadrivium arithmetic geometry
astronomy and music why are these arts
liberal in her award-winning book
cultivating humanity a classical defense
of reform
in liberal education martha nussbaum
writes of what she calls
quotes an education that is liberal
in that it liberates the mind
from the bondage of habit and custom end
quote
since she holds a phd in classics from
harvard university
professor nussbaum knows better the
adjective liberal comes from the latin
word liber
free not a slave according to aristotle
free people
act after deliberation and discussion
while slaves obey without debate
over the centuries the liberal arts have
educated students
from many roles in many societies
ancient medieval and modern in america
and especially in the age of the
founders the freedom of the liberal arts
has been first and foremost the freedom
of a citizen
thomas jefferson for instance wrote to
his state legislator colonel
charles yancey on january the 6th
1816 quotes if a nation
expects to be ignorant and free
in a state of civilization it expects
what never was
and never will be end quotes jefferson
described his bill
for public education in his only book
notes on the state of virginia
final edition 1787
first students should be taught to read
write and reckon
in addition jefferson said quotes their
memories
may here be stored with the most useful
facts
from grecian roman european and american
history
end quotes for thomas jefferson
knowledge of history was as fundamental
and essential as the grammar and
arithmetic
of the seven liberal arts he explains
quotes of all the views of this law the
one on public education
none is more important none more
legitimate
than that of rendering the people the
safe
as they are the ultimate guardians of
their own
liberty for this purpose the reading in
the first stage when they
will receive their whole education is
proposed as has been said to be
chiefly historical history
by apprising them of the past will
enable them to judge of the future
it will avail them of the experience of
other times
and other nations it will qualify them
as judges
of the actions and designs of men
it will enable them to know ambition
under every disguise it may assume
and knowing it to defeat its views and
quotes every citizen should know what
jefferson called
the useful facts of history but the
better educated
should actually read great historians
jefferson wrote young peter carr on
august the 19th since
1785 about studying at william and mary
he wrote quotes i advise you to begin a
course of ancient history
reading everything in the original and
not
translation having described proper
hours to exercise
divide what remains into three portions
give the
principal portion to history the other
two
which should be shorter to philosophy
and poetry and
quotes jefferson urged reading
historians in the original languages
he commented in the notes on the state
of virginia quotes the learning greek
and latin i am told
is going into disuse in europe i know
not what their manners and occupations
may call for
but it would be very ill-judged in us to
follow them
in this instance end quotes
many american founders and english wigs
shared jefferson's belief in the
importance of studying ancient history
one was the english journalist thomas
gordon who lived from 1651 to 1750.
gordon is best known as the co-author
with james trenchert
of a series of 144 political essays
espousing the weak cause in england and
appearing under the pseudonym of
cato the traditionalist contemporary of
cicero
they were published in book form after
trenchard's death
as cato's letters which was a bestseller
in england and the american colonies
bernard bailand of harvard in his study
of colonial pamphlets
called cato's letters quotes the most
frequently cited authority
on matters of principle and theory end
quotes
clinton roster of cornell in seedtime of
the republic wrote quotes no one
can spend any time on the newspapers
literary library inventories
and pamphlets of colonial america
without realizing
that cato's letters rather than john
locke's
civil government was the most popular
quotable
esteemed source for political ideas
in the colonial period and quotes the
memory of cato's letters survives
in the name of the major libertarian
think tank in washington dc
the cato institute it's not named after
an ancient roman
it's named after the pseudonymous author
of cato's letters
after trenchard's death in 1724 gordon
stopped writing fiercely polemical
essays on
contemporary issues and devoted the rest
of his life
to translating two roman historians
tacitus in two volumes
1728 1731 with later revisions
and salast in 1744 he devoted four years
1720 to 1724
to cato's letters but 20 years 1724
to 1744 to ancient history
he prefaced his translations with lively
essays
showing their relevance to the themes of
free institutions
citizenship and tyranny the pages of
tacitus are full of tyrannical emperors
and brave senators who stand up to them
and are defeated the american founders
saw
their world through the lens of tacitus
as adjusted by thomas gordon for john
adams
the morality of tacitus is the morality
of patriotism
you should know that whigs call
themselves patriots
in retirement jefferson wrote i read one
or two newspapers a week
but with reluctance give up even that
much time
from tacitus and horus for john quincy
adams in 1819 when he was secretary of
state
quote to live without a cicero and a
tacitus
at hand seems to me as if it were a
privation
of one of my limbs end quotes
modern historians find it impossible to
believe
that english whigs and american founders
took the past so seriously
stanford's jack raycove writes of the
framers of the u.s constitution
in his pure and surprise-winning book
original meanings
politics and ideas in the making of the
constitution enrico
writes quotes the convention delegates
of 1787-88
came to their task fresh not from
research in their libraries
but from the business of managing a
revolution and conducting public affairs
at
every level of government conscious as
they were
of the fate of other republics and
confederacies ancient and modern
the lessons of the past they weighed
most heavily
were drawn from their own experience and
quotes
is rick overwrite in mid-august
1787 john wilson of pennsylvania and
james madison of virginia
tried to amend the convention's vote on
july the 16th about the two houses of
congress
by moving the bills of appropriation be
allowed to originate
in either house not just the house of
representatives their forceful speeches
were based on
reason and practical political
observation
what reikov calls their own experience
they argued one there was no logical
reason
to restrict such bills from proceeding
from either house
since both houses had to approve the
bills in any event
in addition two the lower houses of
state legislators
had often behaved irresponsibly over the
decades since 1776.
their motion was soundly defeated and
historians rarely mention it
the debate is important however because
of the response it provoked
from distinguished elder statesman john
dickinson
when opposing the amendment expressed
clearly and explicitly
the principles that guided many framers
here we have dickinson's comments by the
way because
madison kept extensive notes on the
debates
in the convention which were published
decades later
dickinson spoke quotes experience
must be our only guide reason
may lead us astray it was not reason
that discovered the singular and
admirable mechanism
of the english constitution it was not
reason
that discovered or even could have
discovered
the odd and in the eyes of those who are
governed by
reason the absurd mode of trial
by jury accidents probably produce these
discoveries
and experience has given sanction to
them
this is then our guide and has not
experienced verified the utility
of restraining money bills to the
immediate representatives of the people
whence the effect may have proceeded he
could not say
but the effect was visible and could not
be doubted
shall we oppose this long experience
to the short experience of 11 years
which we had
ourselves on this subject in quotes
dickinson's rhetorical question refutes
jack rayco's dictum
which was as you remember the lessons of
the past that the framers
weighed most heavily was drawn from
their own experience
in fact almost the opposite is true what
weighed most heavily with the delegates
in philadelphia
during the summer of 1787 was not
what dickinson called the short
experience
of 11 years which we had ourselves which
is what we today
mean when we use the word experience
now what mattered most to them was
english history
and common law which was based on
precedent
for john dickinson and the delegates who
voted with him
experience meant primarily history and
tradition
as historian douglas adair noted quotes
experience shows our history proves
are expressions that are used
interchangeably throughout the
convention
by members from all sections of the
united states and quotes
emmy bradford entitled his book on the
founders
a better guide than reason but that's
not
quite right dickinson did not say that
history and tradition
were better than rationalism he said
experience must be our only
guide the history of the philadelphia
convention
and american history in general needs to
be rewritten
to show americans time and again
privileging biblical
classical german and english history and
tradition
over enlightenment rationalism recent
american history needs to be analyzed
in light of the catastrophic
consequences of privileging and abstract
rationalism
over history and tradition
the founders thought the study of
history essential for education
history as an academic discipline has
seen the steepest decline in measures
of all disciplines since the 2008
recession
according to the american historical
association's journal
perspectives on history why is the
percentage of undergraduates who major
in history
shrunk so much in recent decades
often students prefer stem majors to
humanities and
social and history because they expect
stem
to lead them to good paying jobs
these expectations may be exaggerated
a professor in one prestigious biology
department told a group of colleagues
our majors think they're all going to
med school but only about 20 percent of
them
get accepted according to a report from
the u.s census bureau published on july
the 14th
2014 quotes 74
74 of those who have a bachelor's degree
in science technology engineering and
math
commonly referred to as stem are not
employed in stem occupations and
quotes 74 stem grads
often find that although their first job
does pay more than those of liberal arts
students
they eventually hit a glass ceiling
during the republican
primary debates in 2016 senator rubio
florida opined that america needed
quotes
more welders and less philosophers end
quotes
he meant fewer philosophers but let's
not get distracted here
don't get me started on that one on the
stage debating him
was a stanford graduate with a history
major and a philosophy
minor two subjects often pointed out as
ones that don't lead to
high paying first jobs her first job
indeed was as a secretary
confirming the prejudice her last job
was ceo of hewlett-packard
okay carly fiorina's is an extreme
case i grant you but not unique either
university of colorado president bruce
benson wrote the faculty in august the
4th
2016 that his administration had quote
surveyed the degrees earned by the ceos
of colorado's top 25 companies
we found that most had an undergraduate
degree
in the liberal arts and only then an
advanced degree
in specialized areas such as law or
business
and quotes there is a deeper reason
though for the marginalization of
history
and the arts of language in favor of
stem and the arts of mathematics
for most of western history the seven
liberal arts have proclaimed
the equal value of language and
mathematics
trivium and quadrupium but usually the
arts of language
have been more influential and widely
studied
the growing prestige of plato's vision
of science
as best done by mathematics has
privileged disciplines that use
mathematical models in my experience at
the university of colorado's honors
program
honors theses based on mathematical
models are viewed
as more impressive than those arguing
from history
and political philosophy aristotle
reminded his students that
mathematical models favored by his
teacher plato
need to be confirmed by observation
sometimes history and mathematics
suggests different results
so let me give an example mathematical
models suggest that global free trade
is superior to the products of national
economies
protected by the tariff because goods
are cheaper for consumers
economic history however suggests a
different
conclusion at the time of the american
founding the united states were what we
today
would call a third world economy one
largely agricultural
and producing raw materials for british
factories
the federal government was funded by
tariffs and excise taxes
which taxed foreign countries and
businesses
many americans wanted the tariff used
only to meet the government's budgetary
needs
but others like alexander hamilton
and later henry clay wanted a protective
tariff to favor american industry
over foreign competition when the
republican party achieved a majority in
congress
after the secession of the southern
states in 1861
they passed the protectionist moral
tariff
president james buchanan signed it into
law his last day in office
abraham lincoln later signed two
stronger
versions of the tariff as alfred iaekes
showed in his book
opening america's markets in the century
after the founding the united states
developed
from a producer of raw materials to an
industrial powerhouse
under a regime of national autarky
funded by the tariff
the 16th amendment gave free trader
woodrow wilson
a chance to sabotage the tariff but this
was reversed
by harding and coolidge free traders
attribute the prosperity of the roaring
20s
to lower income tax rates but coolidge
himself in his essay on william mckinley
attributes it to the tariff in this
essay coolidge praises mckinley
because he quotes took up the work of
hamilton and clay
reestablish their principles and under
his leadership
the government re-adopted their policies
end quotes
their principles as the essay makes
plain were protectionism
and their policies the protective tariff
fdr worked to undermine the tariff but
the demolition of america's industrial
base
and the hollowing out of our middle
class really took off
with the kennedy round of gat in the
late 1960s
followed by nafta in the 1990s
of course the roaring 20s ended with the
great depression
marxist blamed it on the inherent
contradictions of capitalism
while free traders blamed the
smoot-hawley tariff
which did not go into effect until the
depression had already begun
milton friedman and anna j schwartz in a
monetary history of the united states
published in 1963 showed that the great
depression was brought on
by the monetary policies of the federal
reserve
it was for this work of economic history
not his advocacy of global free trade
that milton friedman was awarded the
nobel prize for economics
in 1976 if we're to make
rational decisions about our nature's
future economic and otherwise
we need to supplement the lessons of
mathematics with those
of history educators
immerse their students in the past by
studying dead languages
and history progressive educators think
the future will belong
to those who innovate and so our
education
must be innovative support for the
classical model comes from the research
of psychologist
k anders erickson of florida state
erickson studies the most successful
practitioners
of a wide range of different skills and
professions
from policing to chess whom he calls
experts ericsson is the expert
on experts let's examine his research on
chess
chess is a challenging intellectual
activity the communist opinio is
the grand masters win by thinking ahead
more moves than their opponents
erickson's research however shows a
significant correlation
not with innovation but with hours spent
studying the games
of earlier grand masters joshua joshua
foer discusses this
in his book moonwalking with einstein
let me quote foer
quotes using magnetoencephalography
a technique that measures the weak
magnetic fields
given off by a thinking brain
researchers have found
that higher rated chess players are more
likely to engage
the frontal and parietal cortices of the
brain
when they look at the board which
suggests they are recalling
information from long-term memory
lower-ranked players are more likely to
engage the medial temporal lobes
which suggest they are encoding new
information and quotes let me summarize
this research
amateur chess players innovate
grand masters remember
outstanding achievement involves knowing
the past by immersing students in dead
languages in history
the liberal arts aim at creating grand
masters
of citizenship jefferson's view of the
importance of classical literature in
ancient history
from the 1780s did not change after
decades spent
as ambassador to france member of
washington's cabinet
and two terms as president of the united
states in jack rayco's words
quote managing a revolution and
conducting public affairs
at every level of government end quotes
jefferson wrote to nathaniel macon from
monticello
on january the 12th 1819 quotes
i read no newspapers now but ritchie's
and in that chiefly the advertisements
for they contain the only truths to be
relied upon
in a newspaper i regret to say that
thomas jefferson
sometimes criticized our great free
press
jefferson we're all shocked by that so
please
i understand jefferson went on to say i
feel a much greater interest in knowing
what has passed two or three thousand
years ago than what
is now passing i read nothing therefore
of the heroes of troy
of the wars of lassedemon and athens of
pompey and caesar
and of augustus too end quotes
clinton rossiter in his sea time of the
republic described the founders
education quotes it's easy to smile
at the dull rigid crabbed methods that
prevailed
in colonial colleges but if we judge the
vineyards by the fruit
they brought forth we must acknowledge
them of fertile ground
of learning science reason
and liberty they may not have taught
young men enough useful knowledge
but they did teach them in their own
tradition-ridden way
to think communicate and lead
to think communicate and lead
and rossiter goes on the roll call of
harvard and william and mary men
in the revolution should be evidence
enough that latin
logic and metaphysics to which we may
add
ancient history were a rich fertilizer
in the cultivation of reason virtue
honor and love of liberty
progressive educators focus on
liberating students
from the bondage of tradition and the
dead
and of the past they reject studying the
dead languages
that have given us the vocabulary for
philosophy
theology medicine science
law and citizenship and the history of
the athenian democracy
the roman republic and the american
founding
george orwell warned against this
attitude in his novel
1984 when he described the visit of
winston smith
and his girlfriend julia to the
apartment of the government agent
o'brien who treats them to good liquor
and access
to books and conversation not available
to most people sounds like an early
seminar of the center for
constructive alternatives
eventually there's enough alcohol left
for one more toast i hope we won't reach
that condition
tonight and o'brien fills their glasses
what shall it be this time o'brien said
still with the same faint suggestion of
irony
seems to always have the smirk on his
face to the confusion of the thought
police
to the death of big brother to humanity
the future
to the past said winston smith
yes o'brien agreed gravely no more
smirking
yes o'brien agreed gravely
the past is more important
george orwell was a democratic socialist
not a conservative
but he was a cultured man and he knew
that the beauty and freedom we enjoy
are legacies from the past history in a
liberal arts education
teaches students to value our traditions
of language
history and law and employ them to live
as free citizens of a nation founded
with consensual institutions
committed to debate and discussion using
the lessons of history
and the liberal arts of language to
persuade our fellow citizens
and devote ourselves as our ancestors
did
to the cultivation of reason virtue
honor and love of liberty
another reason to study history in the
liberal arts curriculum is that these
stories
whether recounted orally are preserved
in great works of literature
touch our hearts in ways that grammar
and logic do not
the old sunday school hymn used to
proclaim
i love to tell the story shall be my
theme in glory
to tell the old old story of jesus
and his love the hymn makes a point
that's valid for many stories in secular
as well as biblical history i love to
tell the story
because i know it's true it satisfies my
longings as nothing else can do
the minister and robert frost the black
cottage had an insight
we need to hear most of the change
we think we see in life is due to truth
being in and out of favor
as i sit here and oftentimes i wish i
could be monarch of a desert land
i would devote and dedicate forever
to the truth we keep coming back
and back to i like that poem
but i do have a quibble with it lands
that are dedicated to the truths
and stories we keep coming back
and back to are not deserts
they're full of family farms local
factories and churches
their families have a lot of children
their citizens are soldiers
their story is our story
today we like to proclaim nothing is the
same after some
important event if we have to hear about
the past we want it
laid out for us in powerpoint or
download it onto our kindle
so we can skim it on the airplane
give us the gist and if you don't mind
spare us the history lesson
traditional liberal arts education
however insisted on the history lesson
beginning with the ancient greeks and
romans what most americans
value about america consensual
institutions
the rule of law private property science
faith cannot survive without the ancient
traditions
that inspired and maintained them
we are free and creative not because we
inhabit
a new nation dedicated to a proposition
as somebody once said but because we are
citizens
of what general macarthur called the
united states in his last great speech
at west point
quotes this beloved land
of culture and ancient descent
culture and ancient descent in quotes
john adams wrote his friend dr benjamin
rush i should as soon think of closing
all my window shutters
to enable me to see as of banishing the
classics
to improve republican ideas
the liberally educated value the past
and the great works
that preserve that past we all want
progress
cs lewis told his radio audience in 1942
but progress means getting nearer to the
place
you want to be if you're on the wrong
road
progress means doing an about turn and
walking back to the right road
and in that case the man who turns back
soonest
is the most progressive end quote
it's not a question of choosing the
right major
we're on the wrong road we've privileged
job training over the liberal arts
global free trade over family farms and
local businesses
technology over great books the
consensus of self-proclaimed experts
over the wisdom of our ancestors it's
time to turn around
and go back to the right road we shall
recognize it
when we get there because you see
it's the road home thank you for your
kind attention
[Applause]
so if you have a question please make
your way to one of the microphones
i am to remind students that good
questions will be considered for extra
credit
[Music]
us and how we can use it how do we
incorporate that
in today how do we inspire those who are
not inspired from this
we understand reminding you yes
that's a good question and i don't have
a good answer for it one way you
my impression of inspiring students
and there actually is research
supporting it is that
love what you teach be enthusiastic
about your country
and its story uh and the stories that
lie behind it
i had a friend in our education school
his research showed that
the most effective part of teaching more
than knowledge
and more than skill was thinking your
subject was important
and he said this is a bizarre it's the
one thing we can't
teach is the most important thing is
think it matters
once that happens especially when you
rely on the fact that
these people the people that
our founders found important were the
people that the people of the
reformation era found important the
people that dante and petrarch
found important the this is ezra pound
says somewhere
writings and people that have been found
to be interesting and important
for thousands of years are probably not
very boring
and we sort of need to have confidence
that this is true this
there's a sense that especially when you
teach classics you really notice this
when is the day going to come when
people are going to say this is
ridiculous this was thousands of years
ago
how can this possibly matter
to us now and the answer is you sort of
need to believe that it does
and john dickinson's point is the one
that really is relevant here
this is what has made sense for people
for a long long time
and it's not just john dickinson the
18th century frankly the argument that
dickinson uses
the argument about accidents probably
produce this and and
experience showed history show that it
worked is the same argument used by the
great biologist conrad lorenz
in his book on mankind's
mortal sins where he as a biologist
compares the traditions well what one of
mankind's mortal
sins is is every song detroited sion
destroying tradition
and he says tradition of our ethical and
our religious traditions
and our political traditions too i would
add uh he he views like the human genome
which he didn't think was created or
designed
he think it happened because accidents
caused mutations and good mutations
survived
but it comes to the same thing and he
says
the great traditions the ethical and
religious tradition of mankind
have the same validity that that our
genome does and nobody could invent
either one group or the other group what
you need to do is
be confident that that's true when
you're looking at it that is don't look
at it as something that
and this is the problem i have with
martha nussbaum of course she assumes
that the past is wrong and that
tradition is irrational instead of
assuming that something that's made
sense for so long
it's going to continue to make sense if
we just give people a chance to hear it
does that respond to it yes thank you
thank you so much for your wisdom and
exhortation i'm wondering
for those of us who strive and desire to
be scholars of history
when we see history beginning to repeat
itself
and when history itself is the best
testimonial
to those who are deaf to its very
prophecy
is there any room or how much room is
there for
compromise when it comes to our
culture's desire
for stem answers
i suppose when people don't want to
listen to history
but history holds the answers how much
room is there for us to compromise when
it comes to
warning them of the very thing that is
likely to repeat itself
well here i mean you're bringing up a
really good point
and um the fact is we have an
unfair advantage because they you know
have to write you know you've all seen
call rove writing these things on the
on the white board and numbers and on
and on but the fact is where people
people respond to stories and
and heroes and villains much more than
they do to numbers
now sometimes that's wrong and sometimes
the numbers
tell us things we need to listen to but
for the most part
we get to bring in the heroes and the
villains and the stories that really
make sense
to more people and to ourselves also
the really wonderful book on the
founders and the classics
has a wonderful title which is the
founders and the classics
and it's by a great wonderful scholar
name called rashar
and it's spelled richard but he's a
cajun and he like the french leave off
the last
the last letter and his uh book includes
a chapter on
the heroes and the villains who are the
heroes and the villains
and some of these of course are people
that changed places at other times
julius caesar was a villain back in the
18th century
um a hundred years later the great
liberal uh classicist
theodore monson caesar was what was a
hero and
and for dante um bruce and cassius are
in the lowest part of hell
they're right next to judas because they
were disloyal to
to their emperor so so the heroes and
villains may change sometimes
for different reasons but for the most
part these are
these are things we can make to come
alive for people because they were alive
so i think we have the unfair advantage
if we'll take
advantage of and we'll insist wait a
second
i'm going to believe those models when
it comes out that way
but they don't all come out that way
does that make sense thank you
hello thank you for your time um i was
curious about
tradition um because it seems like
when you refer to tradition it almost
seems as if there's a golden age that we
sort of look back to
is that fair to say or is there a sort
of standard that we
look back to it seems as if almost every
decoration would have to look back
tradition i guess
where are we supposed to look back to as
sort of the standard if
like we look back to just as far as the
american foundation or back to
middle ages or farther
right um great question and the
the the the success or the
um argument for the great traditions
is precisely that they've been through
so many ages
and one of the points that conrad lorenz
makes even more clearly than john
dickinson
is that no one person or
study group or generation could come up
with the human genome or the
great moral traditions anyone who's read
cs lewis's
uh um a book we got quoted here
he lists all the common commonalities
of uh of ethical tradition all over the
world in the abolition of man
and um the the argument is precisely
that no one generation has it all that
tennyson says in his arthurian poem
somewhere
the old order changes making way for the
new and god fulfills himself
in many ways lest one good custom should
destroy the world
there there not only is not a pure
golden age
but they're the whole point of these
traditions ethical political
um etc are religious it's precisely
they've been through so many different
ages
now the i mean the i don't want to
present an argument from christianity
that doesn't involve the holy ghost
obviously
but here's something that's been through
antiquity
the middle ages and the modern world
it's known
a lot more than anybody now could know
now let me just modify what i just said
by by bringing up the point we had about
that heroes and
and villains every healthy society every
healthy person
has somebody he views as a kind of hero
and every healthy society has some age
that they view as a wonderful age but
when you
when you honor it and you honor those
you honor them for the good things
and you know there are bad things too
whereas the great traditions that have
made their way
through so many ages so many peoples
and so many times that's the thing that
i would argue for
in favor of tradition and why i would
argue again for history because history
allows us to look when these things
worked and are there times when they
didn't work
does that make sense thank you
thank you for speaking to us today
you were referring a lot to how the
founders
took into context um these these greats
from the past and all of them paid
attention to many of the same people
but even among the founders these people
who are reading the same works from the
same people
they had different not even
interpretations but you could say
different
applications of the same lessons can you
speak to how
even though lessons from history
are unchanging our interpretations of
them
are changing how do we know how to apply
history correctly
and not in a twisted manner maybe by
twisted by our own personal experiences
or the age in which we live so i'm going
to let aristotle answer this question
and one of his points and he makes this
in the ethics and he makes it
in on on the soul is that there are
people that are experts in
a little area and they're really good in
that area
but they can't connect it to the wider
society they live in
and for for aristotle and for plato
there are these archetectonic
um visions and for example for aristotle
economics
is subordinate to politics i know
many people who think it shouldn't be
that way that economics
economists should be telling the
politicians what to what to do
but that the idea that there's a
the point is that a liberally educated
person
a person educated to be a citizen has
that kind of education
how to use the opinions of um
of smart people so i will say a couple
of things that i said
today the leading scholars in the field
don't agree with okay in fact there's a
genuine consensus that the the founders
are
the founding was an enlightenment
project and that it was a distinctly
modern project
and i just don't mean you know the other
side i mean
people on our side really good people on
our side
so i mean it's legitimate i happen to
think the evidence
when evaluated carefully and critically
would show that somebody's right and
somebody isn't right but still there's
legitimate points there to be made and
by the way people who thought
that americans threw away their their
old prejudices
and and um and uh created a new society
uh there's decreed kurz 1782 work
uh letters from an american farmer where
he says exactly that
sounds exactly like bernard bailin and
jack ray cove and martha nussbaum
back in 1782. now i think there were a
lot more people like john dickinson
and thomas jefferson but still
part of a liberal arts education is that
you with a good liberal arts education
can decide what the experts
who are number one in their teeny area
but can't see the whole picture
how this fits into things
so i mean if i'm right if i'm wrong of
course then we should hand over our
lives to
you know dr fauci or whoever the the
expert is
right you laugh there are parts of
boulder that wouldn't be laughing
at that comment um but the fact it's
it's the job of the liberally educated
the people who have a vision
of history of language of philosophy
of literature too uh who should be
judging
what the experts in little areas are
telling us
so that ultimately there is a way to get
a right answer but the openness to
debate is not a
a bad thing that's one of the things
we should be should be learning from the
study of the past
does that make sense thank you
thank you so much for your thought this
is sort of related to what you were just
talking about but what are your thoughts
on the idea of
allowing or requiring students to major
in a certain subject
um at a liberal arts college and because
someone would say that
that's not a true liberal arts education
and then also are there certain majors
that don't really
fit with a liberal arts situation
so it's a really good question i don't
have a really good
answer for it the idea of majors is
something of a concession to a
developing
situation uh the advantage of
departments is they allow a certain kind
of
academic standard to be maintained and
the disadvantages
they tend to leave out things that don't
fit into their
narrow academic specialty are there
things that shouldn't be
part of an undergraduate liberal arts
education
well all we have to do is go to the same
issue of um
the american history association's
perspectives in history and
look at the ones that are doing well
since 2008.
they're the ones that shouldn't be there
or go on to forbes and ford's will say
the majors that give you the best first
job right and list these things and it's
computer science and it's all kinds of
engineering things
and i'm saying that a little bit
carefully because actually classics
isn't the top 20 in the list
with the classics made you actually as a
rule
according to forbes i don't know this
myself but according to forbes who would
question forbes
not i certainly um i think the classics
may just now they're top 20 they're not
top 10 the top 10 are all
computer science stuff and i also get
this
because i'm always having trouble with
my computer and i go in
to the library where they are and
there's the kids fixing it they're all
undergraduates and i remember one
telling me and after he told me this i
asked others it turned out to be true
when i came here i was going to be a bio
major then i found out
only about 20 of them even get to med
school so
i by the way provoked the statement that
i just mentioned
from the for from the colleague
confirming what the student had heard
so i i switched to to to computer
science
because that way i'm guaranteed to get a
good first job
and he's right guaranteed is too much of
course but but
the the the it is it's better than one
in five
i'm supposed to eating my nemo which is
sort of what you get
the the other way so i mean those are
the subjects we shouldn't be teaching
my school i went to a small liberal arts
school haverford college
500 men smaller than you guys
by the way it's bloated since then they
let in women it's now 1100 so it's
exploded but they just sent us
propaganda to make us give more money
and one of the arguments was
10 years ago there was one computer
science major and now there are 40.
isn't this good and i thought well you
know it certainly makes it easier in my
checkbook when you tell me things
which i'm completely opposed to on
principle
these people they should be studying
mathematics they should be studying
science
they shouldn't be studying at a liberal
arts school they should be
learning to be the the the call of
fiorinas
of these businesses in 10 and 15 years
which is what you guys are going to be
by the way
you can tell your parents that anyhow if
you want to i once was teaching at a a
a course for one of our courses done in
a dorm we were trying to
thought it was a great idea to teach
people in their dorms
and it was a greek history course and
two kids came up to me after about a
month and said
ancient history is so great i was going
to be a
a physics major but i'm thinking of
becoming a history major
and i said one you should follow
what you find important two your parents
are gonna hire a hitman from miami to
kill me
because they're gonna think you've
committed career suicide by leaving
a science a stem subject and going
going into this so please warn me if you
see large sums of money in your
parents credit cards going to uh to uh
flights from miami to denver because
i'll know to start protecting myself um
you know basically the more you go back
to the older
liberal arts education this is the
education they gave us dante that gave
us luther and calvin
that gave us aquinas and and william of
lockham frankly they gave us the
founders
and this is the education that prepares
you
to to think communicate and lead
and that's where things like computer
science are distracting
thank you i hope that answers we have
time for one last question
thank you for speaking to us today um my
question is
just have you seen a movement back
towards the liberal arts
or to history in general in any of your
colleagues
or in academia or do you feel like
you're sort of
alone standing in this fight for history
well fortunately i mean if you do your
job properly
and understand that teaching is part of
your job
and you're excited about your subject
there that there are going to be majors
and the languages all of them all the
living ones
except for spanish as well as the dead
ones have had their
their their their problems shortly after
that report from the
census bureau came out talking about 74
of stem undergraduate degrees didn't end
up
doing stem one of the leftist
journals went and investigated it and
now i can't remember which one it was
and what they discovered was that at
yale history was very popular
and i think it was the third most
popular major and at princeton they were
having so many students they were
hiring that's what we really care about
who's getting the faculty positions
right on and on
and their theory was you see who goes to
to yale and princeton but the rich
people who are going to
oppress the rest of us and they were
cleverly
learning about the past and learning
about these traditions
and having the poor pros study these
subjects that led directly to
to a good first job whom they would then
rule of course because they'd be the
ceos
whereas the other guys would be the
other so
there is a rumor that in really good
places which have really good
departments too by the way
good students understand that uh you
know these are important subjects
and i know that that to name a non-ivy
prestige
school basilo prestige school ut austin
created some wonderful humanities
departments
just by paying people at the ivs
more than they got paid there and luring
them off and creating wonderful french
and classics and
german and history departments you know
because it was because
there were majors now i will say our
administrators don't think that
they i was at a meeting where they the
provost came in and said of course i
love the liberal arts
and i would support it and i was silly
enough to say we know that's great
because you know you could create
the greatest classics or french or
history department in the world
with half of what it costs you to hire
junior faculty
in our biology departments and our and
our physics departments
our chemistry departments where you need
labs and all this tremendous
infrastructure and of course the look on
his face he
tell when someone isn't sincere right
well yeah well we could hire those
people but then when no students took
their courses what would we do
we'd be stuck with them so i said okay
thank you sir thank you i didn't
understand thank you for
for clarifying that so there is some
evidence
that smart people know enough to study
the great subjects
but in terms of the sheer numerical
aspect
what was true a few years ago is still
true
the humanities are in trouble as far as
enrollments go
thank you thank you
thank you ladies and gentlemen